here's what happened in the Portugal
Morocco World Cup quarterfinal
[Applause]
Striker Cristiano Ronaldo once again
started on the bench and the and the
first half was pretty even until the
42nd minute when this happened
[Applause]
Morocco's Striker Yusuf and nasiri beat
Portugal's keeper Diego Costa to a cross
and headed Morocco into the lead two
minutes later Portugal midfielder Bruno
Fernandez fired a shot from way out
but it hit the post Morocco LED at
halftime in the 51st minute Ronaldo came
on for Portugal his 196th International
appearance equaling the world record and
Portugal came close to scoring a Joelle
Felix shot late on was heading in but
Morocco keeper Yasin bunu denied him
with an incredible save at the start of
injury time Morocco Striker Waleed
shadira was sent off so Morocco were
forced to defend their lead with 10 men
for eight nerve-wracking minutes of
added time but then
foreign
the final score the atlas Lions Advanced
to their first World Cup semi-final the
first ever for an African nation
[Applause]